des champignons rendre aux ongles
d'orteil jaune opaque et cassin hendrix
affirme qu'il a la solution pour tenter
cette infection mtx est il vraiment
efficace
une étude scientifique a été menée pour
tester le traitement hendrix sa
conclusion
l'infection aux champignons a disparu
dans seulement 27,2 % des cas et les
participants à cette étude ont dû
utiliser un tricks à tous les jours
pendant presque six mois mais il y a
plus ce genre d'infections peut être
causée par notre état de santé
la sudation excessive ou le frottement
de l'ongle sur la chaussure
si on n'intervient pas sur ces facteurs
il y a de fortes chances que tout le
traitement soit à recommencer et sachant
qu'un tube d'hendrix coûte plus de 48
dollars c'est un pensez y bien